does Jan have heavies
because there's a name that we have for
people like that who we used to call
them Tiff McGee I'm sorry
[Music]
so um it's gonna be too easy to crap on
this person so the rule for this one is
say something nice okay so we got to get
his back or her back this is my favorite
say something nice okay easy not easy
there's a school a very prestigious
school where you have to be really smart
to go to it's called the burn Science
and Tech Charter School in Oak Hill it's
tough already uh there's a principle of
this club her name's Jan McGee
that's a funny name it's tasting nice
guys that's the person we're talking
about is Jan a lady or a man lady doctor
Jan she's beautiful does Jan have
heavies
because there's a name that we have for
people like that who we used to call
them Tiffany I'm sorry
all right hey Jan has been have he's in
the office she does have heavy so
imagine hurry okay Jen Dr J McGee she is
now resigning from her position because
she has only found herself she's got
Heavies no it's because she did
something kind of dumb she uh she
thought she was a careless mistake it's
okay she thought she was talking to Elon
musk's right-hand man and she signed him
a hundred thousand dollar check in
school funds
let's kill this mistake got catfish if
it happens a lot happens to kinesthetics
literally yesterday it's fine
[Laughter]
just tell the truth guys oh that kind of
hurts
say something nice smart I did I said
lots of nice things that was nice people
move on move on with the details does
that get fixed by the way no not yet oh
no it was a characteristics it literally
happens all the time it's okay you're
clicking on links you're you're on
PornHub you're clicking on all kinds of
links and hey [__] happens hey dude you
know sometimes you gotta watch porn from
the clothing account and feel free to
use this moment to purchase some stuff
at store.kinja.com you want to share
what happened you could go to Alibaba
too if you want maybe someone can help
we are we are looking for help from
anybody who like is it knows somebody
Instagram that can help us get our
account back but they did work it on
Facebook work out Instagram hit them up
yeah they did they did post in the IG
stories for kinesthetic said something
like uh I saved it it's being held for
ransom right basically yeah they said
it's so [__] up it said this account
will be refunded for money
and that's just posted as text so they
basically took the kinju's uh
kinesthetic account on IG and they're
holding it for ransom until someone pays
up dude that's so crazy hey that's
that's what I'm saying Jan McGee is not
alone that's true if they're smart
they'll ask Anthony for BNB because he
has a lot of that yeah get some BNB dude
we're gonna put that on plastic I was
just I was just thinking the crazy thing
is that she's the principal of this
school she has a doctorate and she still
really believed she was speaking to Elon
musk's right how old is this lady does
it say in the article how old she is she
looks old she looks up there some of the
most book smart people aren't Street
Smart though oh yeah I [__] know man
um when it comes to principals out of
school isn't their job to do stuff like
this though is to find like like a
thousand dollars well well it's like um
they do a lot of like campaign funding I
I never knew it was the other way I knew
that it was like finding donors for the
school yeah the other way is not sort of
funny dude who's Elon musk's right hand
man it's probably his Twitter account
elon's right hand man Gustavo hey
everyone knows everybody knows Gustavo
and everybody knows how tight he is okay
I'm thinking about Gus break the other
one yeah
this camera's smart
because one Elon Musk would never
message like a junior high scores by
like well maybe he will actually but but
it's like it's harder to believe dude
Elon Musk has to make this right but if
I was like if I was a scammer I would
say I'm a representative of Jeff bezel's
Enterprise yeah okay that's good so far
I'm in yeah oh I love this so she was
trying to secure like you said she was
trying to secure a six million dollar
funding donation did they [__]
Nigerian scammer But You Gotta Give me
100k if you give me 100k first if you
give me 100k I can give you five million
because I need your money first
real yeah yeah she uh that is
yeah like when I was by
kind of works you know what I don't
understand is
people that are older than us right
they've been on this Earth longer than
they're supposed to be more Street Smart
they're supposed to be wiser but why the
[__] are they the ones getting exploited
it's the technology part of it though no
but Nigerian scammers aren't tech savvy
they're just sending an email or like
they're calling yeah like but at the
time that was a big development right
like email and I think it's taking
advantage of people's like their
personal greed and their greed gets the
best of their experience it's the hope
that they instead yeah that's the game
they're also good at sales though yeah
because like they can yell at an old
lady who's like hey I think my
Microsoft's got got hacked and then
they're like well hi I'm with hello
ma'am I am with Microsoft you need to
get us like a 500 Applebee's gift card
right now
and then this lady's like [__]
stressed out she's in Best Buy she's
like where's the Applebee's gift card
yeah I'm also wondering when is the
generational Gap gonna show where we're
getting scammed by something like kids
are like you idiots like what it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen I don't think
so I hope it doesn't happen
but yeah I hope it doesn't too Bart I
think it was night I don't think
naiveness is H because there's like
older people that do read these stupid
emails and they go what the [__] or like
you know right now there's a lot of hot
Chinese girls that are lonely let me
tell you they randomly text us bro let
me tell you yeah I get there's three of
those messages a day you're like I can't
stop getting those messages and they're
all cuties I gotta say yeah I'm trying
to think of they're all the same girl
too which is oh really it's all the same
okay Simon or something yeah something
I'm trying to figure out a way for to do
Ryan type of stuff to them no you
shouldn't never respond really because
what you what happens when you respond
to those is they they flag you as an
active number yeah you open the line of
communication you big dummy hey they
never respond back to me Ryan doesn't
any funny but I don't do it and then
they show up at the office
well they don't respond to me oh they
don't yeah and maybe some
nurse yeah yeah
usually kind of know because so many
people have started just kind of messing
with them they kind of know when to move
on because it's like
say one thing like hi and they don't
talk I'm being rejected by [__] Bots
oh you're actually just talking normal
the Chinese lady I can't even get to the
Trap like I'm not even trolling I'm just
going like let's say uh uh they'll sell
they'll send a group photo right it's a
bunch of like cute girls they're like I
had so much fun last night or whatever
and I'm all like oh who is this
like it's a normal response right it
goes oh I think you got the wrong number
nothing
I think they really did get the wrong
number now sorry to hear that dude that
sucks because I want to get that juicy
[__] just trying to get trapped y'all
but I can't I I can't even get there
dude yeah that's hard dude yeah send
them a dick pic next time see if they'll
respond yeah just immediately send a
dick pic yeah just see what happens say
hey I can't believe you're not
responding to me here's my date
hey remember last night when you saw my
dick here it is again
sucks for this um for Jan though because
of course like in her field it's not
going to be easy for her to get another
principle that's a bit Yeah you miss
managed funds dude is that a oofy doofy
Steve I think that's gonna be a new
video that's six figures unless they
could stop payment on the check then
it's just an oofy yeah 100 000. here's
here's what she looks like is that is
that old do you think she old enough
that's pretty old is that hundred
thousand dollar check old she looks like
a mummy kind of like a [__] mummified
woman but how often do you think it's
like they do these where they talk back
and forth with these organizations right
yeah and it's just standard protocol and
then one just slip through the cracks
you know yeah I mean like you might be
talking to [__] the the executives at
Target or like so this is right hand man
yeah that's true maybe there's other
conversations where they are really put
the protocol to get funds no way is
there send me six figs but sometimes um
if you guys follow Elon which I do yeah
on Twitter sometimes she's like hey if
you guys send me a Bitcoin I'll send you
two Bitcoins back I'm only do this for
like a couple more hours
so it's kind of a simple thing right man
his right hand man does it got a check
mark next to his name though you're
probably not following the one with the
check mark was it was it Gustavo Elon
musk.com
they have those videos too you're
watching like something on on YouTube
right and there's a related video and
it's like Elon like talking to people
and then they have this like little
Chiron it's like giving away like one
eat for every uh every 0.5 each you send
to me right now or like send it to this
address and like people fall off that
[__] they really think that it's real I
would wow see it's not just old people
that fall for stupid [__] I think more
young people fall for stupid [__] than
old people because right now who's
getting catfished the most who's getting
scammed the most but it's young people
horny people yeah Guys these scammers
are so good at painting the dream like
they paint everything perfectly it's the
dream havers that's true because they're
already like because I think for me it's
hard for me to get scams I'm so cynical
yeah I already don't believe you right
off the bat I think you're scared and
there's nothing that you can offer that
I want yeah but the people that are oh
you have that oh oh I do want that oh
you can get it they're more vulnerable
right yeah that's where your
vulnerability happens I think you get
thirst trapped yes you're too thirsty
for money too thirsty for [__] too
thirsty for emotions that's Jed's fault
she's too thirsty for [__] she thought
she was gonna hook up with Elon Musk if
you're out at Applebee's and you put up
the 500 gift card they should just
arrest you immediately that's true so we
got the son of a [__] nobody gets 500.
unless they're scandals the crazy thing
though is that she's being good yeah for
a month two for 20. she's being put in a
position where people are relying on her
to not be scammed like you're handling
School funds like you kind of have to
not be yeah you got a doctorate for this
reason we got it you've been laying on
this chick pretty hard the whole video
but she claims that she was groomed into
it oh she does dude what does that even
mean I mean she fell in love with him
maybe he flirted with her
she was lonely bro you see people's like
[__] change you know when you're like
walking out the mall or at some outdoor
shopping center the people that suck ass
are like hey you need a cell phone or
you want a thump whatever bracelet
they're just already throwing them
get the [__] away from me but then the
guys that are like oh those shoes look
nice on you people's like they have like
a resting [__] face they kind of
already melt you know so if they if they
just even said oh like hey oh you're a
doctor that's so awesome must be really
smart like I am pretty smart um
[Laughter]
she's all the way away from the computer
she goes oh wait you got my attention
has two drumsticks in her hands
are just changed
dude that's a great hey you got some
Heavies over there for a principal oh my
God you're the first person I've noticed
this like looking closer at the screen
yeah fixing her tits and [__] yeah they
can't even see it through the email
she's getting fluster before she's like
oh okay comes back to school the next
days unbuttons a couple buttons see if I
can talk to elon's right hand again I'm
gonna get my bounciest chair have you
ever spoken to someone who's been cat
like who's actually in the midst of
beating being catfished they're they're
crazy to now like people that are being
scam catfish Ed all that like don't
it got to the point where I'm like you
know what you deserve this [__] because
you're so [__] stubborn get scammed
my uncle convinced my grandma that he
won like 55 grand in like some [__]
contest thing and like he just needed to
send them twelve hundred dollars like
the same [__] God yeah he was like
telling her all this stuff and then my
family's like yo this is a [__] scam
and he's like you guys are [__]
haters and all this [__] same [__] right
but then like later that night my dad
was able to show him hey look this is
the scam people are doing it was like
exactly what he won and then he was like
devastated
55 G's it's actually you hate to be the
one to show them I love it
I love tea
[Music]